so what i hope to do in this video is
get some familiarity with the graph of
tangent
tangent of theta and to do that i'll set
up a little unit circle
so that we can visualize what the
tangent of various thetas are so let's
say that's a y-axis
this is my x-axis
that is my x-axis and the unit circle
would look something
something like this
and we already know this is all a
refresher of the unit circle definition
of trig functions that if i have an
angle an angle theta where one side is
the positive x-axis and then the other
side so this is
the other side so the angle is formed
like this that where this ray intersects
the unit circle the coordinates of that
the x and y coordinates are the sine of
theta
sorry the x coordinate is the cosine of
theta so it's the cosine of theta comma
sine of theta
so the x coordinate here
is cosine theta the y coordinate there
is the sine of theta but we're concerned
about tangent of theta well we know the
tangent of theta is the same thing as
the sine of theta
over the cosine of theta
or if you're starting from the origin
and you're going and you're you're
you're taking the value of essentially
the y-coordinate the y-coordinate over
the x-coordinate it's essentially the
slope of this line it's going to be this
is going to be your change in y
change in y
over change in x this right over here is
going to be the slope the slope i guess
you could say of this ray right over
here and so that's going to help us
visualize what the tangents of different
thetas are so let me clean up my unit
circle a little bit
just so that we can all right there we
go
so now let's make a let's make a table
so
let's make a table
so if so for various thetas let's think
about what tangent of theta is going to
be
tangent of theta so maybe the easiest
one if theta is zero radians so if it's
zero radians what is the slope of this
ray well that ray is the slope is 0 as x
changes y doesn't change at all
now let's think about and i'm just going
to pick values that are very easy for us
to think about what the tangent of those
values are and they'll help us form
they'll help us think about the shape of
the graph of y is equal to tangent of
theta
so let's take let's take pi over
pi over 4 radians
so this one right over here theta is
equal to pi over 4. now why is that
interesting and sometimes it's easier to
think in degrees that's a 45 degree
angle
this here your x coordinate and your y
coordinate is the same you might
remember it's square root of 2 over 2
square root of 2 over 2. but the
important thing is
whatever you move in the x direction you
move the same in the y direction so the
slope of this ray right over here is
going to be equal to 1 or another way of
thinking about it tangent of theta is
going to be equal to one or sine of
theta over cosine of theta the same
thing so you're going to get one
so
if you put so let me just
clean that up here just because i'm
going to keep reusing the same unit
circle
so
if i have theta is pi over 4 then the
tangent of theta is going to be equal to
1.
now what if theta is equal to negative
pi over 4. so that is
this right over here
so with x
so let me just draw a little triangle
here
so when x this x coordinate over here is
square root of two over two
we know that
we've seen that multiple times square
root of two actually let me label a
little let me label it a little bit
better
so here our theta is equal to negative
pi over four radians
now or you could if you like to think in
degrees this would be negative 45
degrees
and now your your sine and cosine of
this angle are going to be the opposites
of each other the cosine is square root
of 2 over 2 the x coordinate of where
this intersects the square root of 2
over 2. the y coordinate here is
negative square root of 2
over 2.
so what's the tangent well it's going to
be your sine over your cosine which is
going to be negative 1 and you see that
for however much you move in the x
direction you move the opposite of that
or you move the negative of that in the
y direction and so let me clean this up
a little bit because i want to keep
reusing my unit circle
so
there you go and so this is going to be
negative 1.
this is going to be
this is going to be negative 1. and so
actually let's just start plotting a few
of these points so if we assume that
this is the theta axis
if you can see that that's the theta
axis and if this is the y-axis
that's the y-axis we immediately see
tangent of zero is zero
tangent of pi over four is one i'm
sticking in radians tangent of negative
pi over four
is negative 1.
now let's think right now if you just
saw that you might say well maybe this
is some type of line but we'll see very
clearly it's not a line because what
happens
what happens as our as our angle gets
closer and closer to
as our angle gets closer and closer to
pi over two what happens to the slope of
this line
so that is theta we're getting closer
and closer to pi over two
well this ray i guess i should say is
getting closer and closer to approaching
the vertical so it's slope is getting
more and more and more positive and if
you go all the way to pi over 2 the
slope at that point is really undefined
but it's approaching
one way to think about it is it is
approaching infinity so as you get
closer and closer to pi over 2 so i'm
going to make a
i'm going to draw essentially a vertical
asymptote right over here
at pi over 2
because
it's not going to be i just want to
think about it's approaching infinity
there so
this is going to be looking something
like this
it's going to be looking something like
this the slope of the ray as you get
closer and closer to pi over 2 is
getting closer and closer to infinity
and what happens when
what happens when the angle is getting
closer and closer to negative pi over 2
is getting closer and closer and
negative pi over 2. well then the slope
is getting more and more and more
negative it's really approaching
negative it's approaching negative
infinity so let me draw that
so once again not quite defined right
over there we have a vertical asymptote
and we are approaching
we are approaching
negative infinity we are approaching
negative infinity so that's what the
graph of tangent of theta looks just at
just over this section of i guess we
could say the theta axis but then we
could keep going there we could keep
going
because if our angle right after we
cross pi over 2 so we're let's say we've
just crossed pi over 2. so we went right
across it now what is the slope what is
the slope of this thing
well the slope of this thing is hugely
negative right it looks almost like what
i just drew down here it's hugely
negative
so then the graph jumps back down here
and it's hugely negative again it's
hugely negative and then as we as we
increase our theta as we increase our
theta it becomes less and less and less
negative all the way to when we go to
what is this
all the way until we go to let me plot
this
angle right over here now what is this
angle this if i haven't told you yet
this let's say that this angle right
over here is three pi over four
now why did i pick three pi over four
because that is pi over two
that is pi over 2 plus pi over 4. or you
could say 2 pi is over 4 plus another pi
over 4 is 3 pi over 4. and the reason
why this is interesting is because it is
another it's forming another i guess you
could say pi over 4
pi over 4 pi over 2 triangle or 45 45 90
triangle
where the x and y coordinates or the x
and y distances have the same magnitude
but now the x is going to be negative
and the y is positive so the slope here
is going to be the slope at the same
slope as we had for negative
pi over 4 radians we're going to have a
slope of negative 1.
so
at 3 pi over 4 we have a slope of
negative 1.
then we increase our angle all the way
to pi
now our slope is back to zero
our slope is back to zero
and then
as we go beyond that as we go to as we
increase by another as we increase by
another pi over four our slope goes back
to being positive one
our slope goes back to being positive
one and then once again as we approach
three pi over two our slope is becoming
more and more and more positive getting
approaching positive approaching
positive infinity the slope notice if
you move a little bit in the x direction
you're moving a lot up in the y
direction so once again so now the graph
is going to look like this let me
do it in a color that you can actually
see
the graph is going to look
something
like
something like this and it will just
continue to do this it will just
continue to do this every
every
pi
radians
every actually we do that as a dotted
line
every
pi radians over and over and over again
so let me go back
pi and i can draw these asymptotes
i can draw these asymptotes and so let
me draw that and that and so the graph
of tangent
the graph of tangent of theta is going
to look
is going to look something
something like this and we could
obviously it's periodic we could just
keep doing it on and on and on in both
directions